e
so um I'm just going to call this
subcommittee meeting to order it's uh
about 10:05 we're missing our chair
right now so um excuse my uh doing this
kind of on the Fly um I'd like to um all
Allegiance the pledge of algi to the
flag United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all Adam I'd love you to introduce
yourself and uh and proceed with your
presentation we're very um very grateful
you oh okay I thought red was bad okay
sorry uh I have been watching your
subcommittee every moment for the last
six months from from afar so it's good
to be here and see you all in person uh
Adam finle I live in Dalton um uh most
of the year I have an unheated place so
I live in Princeton New Jersey part of
the year and I really appreciate the
chance to come and talk uh to the
subcommittee about how regulations are
written vetted
prioritized proposed implemented
defended enacted and enforced in most of
the country and most of the world now I
love New Hampshire I worked here in the
80s uh on Mount Washington been trying
to get back here for all that time and
it's an exceptional State uh and it
should remain that way but it is it is
an outlier with respect to the
administrative State and so I'm hoping
to start a I think a a needed but long
conversation about how to modernize the
way regulations are done in this state
picking some of the good features of
other jurisdictions staying exceptional
in other ways but in order to understand
how different it is here you need to
understand how it's done almost
everywhere else and for how long it's
been done differently and in my view
better whatever that means
uh just a little uh background about
myself I have very broadly trained I've
tried to remain a generalist so I've
been on the faculties of schools of
medicine Law Public Policy uh and now
public health um but for 15 years uh I
was in the federal government in the uh
federal system I was the chief rule rule
writer and regulator at the occupational
safety and health administration uh OSHA
under President Clinton and then
president uh bush
43 uh I was for a few years the chief
oan enforcement official and a big swath
of the country uh in the uh Rocky
Mountain and and Midwestern
states uh but I bring a lot of federal
experience but I've also advised and
worked with and worked for uh numerous
states and cities and other countries so
I have a short list here of states that
I've advised so I know how State
Environmental agencies work uh as well
and how I wrote an ordinance for
Philadelphia on on chemical and dry
cleaning I worked in Mexico City uh and
I think the the uh takeaway here is that
uh as I'll say I'm going to get to my
sort of bottom line in just a couple
more slides uh and then feel free to
once I get the the two big points out
feel free to interrupt and ask questions
but um couple of slides about uh my
background um so I'm a primarily a
public health scientist but I I taught
at a law school they were very nice to
keep me around for uh for eight years at
at University of Pennsylvania uh but
among other things I'm one of two people
in the country who have been chosen by
the National Academy of Sciences uh uh
to be on their their two committees that
have uh occurred at 15-year intervals to
look at how risk is assessed and managed
in the federal government so the first
of such report was in 1994 uh another
one in 2009 and the uh the third person
unfortunately is since passed but uh two
of us remaining who were chosen both in
94 and 2009 to to look at the federal
system and again I'm a scientist but I I
am strangely proud of this this is the
most important administrative law
journal and it's been around for uh 66
years um 76 years excuse me and I
somehow have the second most downloaded
uh article from that uh Journal over all
that
time uh but my other uh very enjoyable
and very educational experience was was
the founding executive director of a
program in regulation at the University
of Pennsylvania Law School but drawing
on faculty from uh the whole university
and it's it's probably uh I've been gone
for uh about almost 10 years now but
it's probably the preeminent academic uh
Center studying uh regulation and so the
first slide had our uh our motto it's a
lot of other people's model the wise
restraints that make us free we all want
to be free we live in the in the Live
Free State but as I hope this picture
shows uh the person with the yellow
license plate is enjoying his or her
Freedom by driving the wrong way on the
interstate and everyone else is not
quite as free as they were uh because
this one person is is uh fulfilling his
or her um no one as the boss of me but
without the the the restraints in place
we would have Anarchy on the roads so
this program has put out any number of
of books I brought one of them I've got
some other book covers here uh but
particularly we uh we con conceived and
and led the largest project ever on how
Regulatory Agencies succeed or fail
around the world it was called the
best-in-class initiative it still has
its own website uh was funded by the uh
province of Alberta Canada uh but we
went all over Canada and then remotely
all over the world looking at how
different agencies succeed or fail and
the the the motto there was listen learn
and Lead You have to engage with the
public and I'll show us slide at the
very end with more Graphics about this
but engage with the public uh learn from
them um and then be proactive not just
respond uh belatedly to things that that
you can no longer ignore but but look
forward so here's the takeaway and after
I get through these two slides I'm happy
to to be interrupted uh so as I said we
are an exceptional state but we should
really understand how different the rest
of the country and the rest of the world
is secondly it is it is frankly very
much more difficult for agencies to
regulate or not however they please
everywhere else but but this state as
far as I can tell and having so much
discretion is not good for for business
or for public health in the environment
depending on who's in power and who is
allowing all of this unfettered uh Juris
discretion uh to take
place I've not met too many people who
are more bullish aggressive about the
unfair finished business of public
health and safety and the environment I
a huge supporter of you want to call it
the Deep State or the administrative
State I think these agencies do an
enormous service to the country and the
world and they need staff and funds and
power and discretion and Authority uh
and deference and respect but not too
much not so much that they go off and
either do what they want or do what you
know one person in a position of power
behind the scenes tells them
to do so in a in a in a period of time
when for whatever reasons the agencies
are being told to deregulate or regulate
weekly or regulate not at all uh
business may like that uh but health and
environment suffer which eventually
means the economy suffers but if you
have that kind of system you're
incredibly vulnerable to a change in
politics such that the next thing you
know you have a person in power who is
dict ating that there should be
overregulation
and and businesses going under and uh
prices going up and going too far to as
much as I think it's hard to go too far
to protect Public Health we can go too
far we can over
reggulator economic harm uh when the
agencies can do whatever they please
without these guard rails that that
again almost everyone else has and then
third it's it's been a very very long
time that other states and the federal
system have modernized and these are the
two fundamental ways that I'll talk
about since 1946 the federal and many
state processes have become much more
participatory and much more serious than
the New Hampshire process is that's uh
78 years ago under the Truman
Administration the administrative
procedure Act of 1946 we have an
administrative procedure act in New
Hampshire in the rsas but it's it's very
different and not nearly as strong as
the one that the feds have had for
almost 80 years and then secondly for
for over 40
years the federal government and again
many states have adopted this over over
time has insisted that the central
question that a regulator always has to
ask is not just is this rule legal is it
compliant is it written in English does
it check off all the boxes Is it wise
and the field of risk assessment and
cost benefit assessment has developed
over that time it started even before
that it's actually the Army Corps of
Engineers who invented cost benefit
analysis for dams and other projects in
the 1920s but that's the way that the
federal
government insists on always asking the
question do the benefits of a project or
a rule outweigh their costs and if it if
they don't the government is not
supposed to allow the agency to just go
off and do things that cause more harm
than good right that makes sense but we
don't have that here we never ask Is it
wise and here here's my slide about that
the agencies the legislature the the
four councils for the environmental
agencies JL car for the legislature and
the courts incessantly but only ask is
the rule legal and everywhere else we
ask Is it wise so here's a quote um from
my my binge watching of of these
proceedings this was house Judiciary
earlier this year uh a bill uh to
improve judicial review which in my view
didn't get a very fair hearing uh in the
committee but the chair of the way of
the wetlands Council came Mr Kimble and
said you know very forthrightly we're
not here to protect the environment we
protect the statute and that's that's
true and that's important but that's
very telling that the councils Do Not
are not instructed to think about the
cost and benefits they're just
instructed to think about the
statute so again um I I've been in the
field of cost benefit assessment for 40
years I've helped to invent it and and
modernize it and it's got a lot of
critics and detractors but it's a way of
thinking about goods and harms and it's
structured and it and I'll I think the
next slide well not quite uh sorry um
this is just a picture of Harry Truman
in
1946 um so this is talking about
administrative procedure act and I just
highlighted that as I'll continue to to
elaborate on the the process allows the
affected public it could be business it
could be experts it could be homeowners
uh anybody you know with with voting
rights in in the state or the country to
participate and the federal law says
that a party is entitled to present
their case with oral or documentary
evidence to submit rebuttal evidence to
conduct cross-examination this is how
and I'll show you in a minute an example
this is how public he ings work in other
places but they don't work that way here
and some of us were at a hearing and
conquered what two two three weeks ago
um which I'll describe and you were
there was very different than the way
hearing is and should be and the rest of
the administrative procedure act talks
about what happens at the end when the
courts get hold of it and again
arbitrary and capricious these are words
that people elsewhere learn in the first
week of law school or the first week of
uh policy School um I was incredibly
fortunate at a young age I took
administrative law from a then not very
well-known guy named Steve Brier who
became CH Justice of the Supreme Court
and a brilliant teacher uh but you know
arbitrary and capricious that was just
over and over again that's the way it
works everywhere else you are not
allowed to be arbitrary or capricious
and there are tons of cases that try to
explain what that means and it's it's
going to depend on the judge and depend
on the situation but here we don't have
that here we have
uh hope I got this in the right order
not yet uh but anyway we we our
administrative procedure act talks about
uh things like clear error of fact or
law or uh the agency acted unlawfully or
unreasonably and that unreasonably is a
little bit close to arbitrary but it's
not nearly strong enough so that a court
can actually listen to whether it's the
business or the public coming in and
saying we tried our best through the
whole process to get some common sense
here and we we haven't gotten it we're
looking to the courts to
believe us that the agency acted
arbitrarily and it doesn't happen here
almost all rules are upheld because the
courts are instructed by Statute to only
look at um clear errors of factor law
and that's just not
enough and then the other piece of it is
this cost benefit piece so this is from
New York Times 1981 uh Ronald Reagan is
the one who put the executive order in
place that said you can't regulate first
of all you have to show that there's a
market failure which basically means
that we need government to come in and
correct something if the market can do
it then the the the bias is we don't
need guard rails let the market solve
the problem but if there's a market
failure pollution is cheap so the
polluter just pollute because no one
prices it properly that's when you need
uh the EPA to come in and say no it
can't be free it has to be you have to
compensate or you have to uh uh regulate
so this uh Time Magazine said this was
one of nine executive orders that
changed American history I forget when
they said that but probably over you
know hundreds of years um and so that
executive order again it's been in full
effect for all that time uh has created
a system in the federal government and
some states have now mimicked this where
in addition to all the public process
I'm going to talk about there is an
internal process in the executive branch
uh and so it's in in the federal system
it's the Office of Management and budget
and they have a subgroup called oira the
office of information and Regulatory
Affairs and now the head of that office
has been called for some decades the
regulatory
Zar uh now in the agencies we didn't
like frankly we didn't like these people
we didn't like any any of the Zars we
didn't like their staff
but they did a lot of good they forced
us to come in day after day month after
month and justify what we were doing
because we were all part of the
executive branch and the was the
president's delegate to
say usually frankly and they will admit
it they were saying we need these rules
to be a little less strict and a little
more flexible for business that's our
we're economists that's what we do uh
but also a lot of science a lot of
procedure uh a lot of meetings where we
came out of it kind of angry that you
know we lost something or you know we it
was round seven and we got you know hit
in the face but we came out of it with a
better rule than when we came in because
smart people were who were not um
obsessed with you know this chemical or
this Hazard were taking a fresh look and
saying well actually you know you could
you could get most of what you want in a
different way and and we're going to
pretty much force you to do it that way
because we have the authority but again
that was a checkin balance that that
just does not exist
here uh again the field of cost benefit
and risk assessment it's I heard I
forget who it was but I heard somebody
on the committee uh on the on the
YouTube a few months ago
saying what do you mean we're going to
estimate the the
monetary U value of some protection and
we're going to compare it to the
economic cost that seems like Voodoo to
me person didn't use the word voodoo but
seemed kind of surprised that that that
that could even be done well believe me
it's been done every day of every week
for 50 plus years and there people I've
devoted a part of my career but I know
many people who've devoted their entire
academic professional lives to studying
these problems and and doing this kind
of work so we have a journal that has 12
articles a month for 44 years now uh and
and lots of other academic journals um
if you want to look at it later here's
the current issue of the Journal of
benefit cost
analysis don't want to show any numbers
or any uh uh you know any math here but
just to give you a sense so this is the
naal highway traffic safety
administration now we have to have
cameras in all of our Passenger cars
it's been phased in over time but new
cars have to have this little camera and
the reason for the camera is that people
were obviously keeping track and uh I
forget the exact number but it was a
dozen or more kids three years and under
were were killed every year by being
backed up over by Passenger cars and
unfortunately it was typically the the
the child's own parent who didn't see
the child playing behind the station
wagon in their
driveway uh and so there is you know the
techniques are uh you I have no time to
go into this is a whole semester of of a
course but there are well-developed
economic techniques to say it's
subjective but how much is a life worth
well how much is an injury worth how
much are people willing to pay uh to
avert an injury or to avert a fatal
accident and of course the price of the
camera is you can get that from the
catalog and the price goes down always
because we make more of them and learn
how to make them cheaper but Nitsa said
the the benefits
of reducing by some and and and they can
of course estimate how you're not going
to prevent every fatality by having a
camera people won't look at their
cameras but there's studies that say if
you have a camera you're less likely to
run over an object you can't see uh and
so they compare those two things and
they went to the the government they
went to the public went to the court and
said we think it's a good idea to save
kids lives by requiring the price of a
car to go up by it turns out about $70 a
car to have this technology in place and
it got through the system and it went to
court and the judges said yeah this
makes sense to
us uh and a similar one I just finished
uh last year working for the consumer
product safety commission uh on the we
don't have them here but uh Venetian
blinds with with the strings on them the
strings strangle about 10 babies every
year because they are left alone and
they get caught in the qu of course you
can make Venetian blinds without strings
that go down to the level where a baby
can can grab onto it but that's that
costs money so you have to do cost
benefit and another rule that's tied up
in court but we think it will uh
Prevail so now I have about seven or
eight slides that I don't want anybody
to to read or or but I want to give a
visual impression of
how regimented and and uh I don't want
to use the word cumbersome because I do
believe this is all for the good but
when you compare it to the New Hampshire
process which is
basically the agency says we feel like
writing a rule or we have to update a
rule um here's a proposed rule we're
going to have a listening session for an
hour or two where we don't really we we
listen but we don't hear uh and then
here's the final which looks very much
like the proposal maybe exactly like the
proposal and let's go to jail car and
have a little happy talk and let them
rubber stamp it uh and then we're okay
because the courts don't the courts
defer to us the federal system in many
states have a just an incredibly
different process so rather than show
these slides of steps one through nine
and specific analyses required and a
whole different uh set of uh charts that
a consulting firm puts out every year
called the reg map uh this one is like
you know building the space shuttle with
all of these arrows going back to other
arrows and colorcoded
things I'll I'll just try in like two
minutes to go through a typical process
at at the federal
level uh so basically and again just to
give the the flavor that that this is
very foreign to what goes on here first
of all you can't just in the federal
system in many states you can't just
announce that like here's our proposed
rule there has to
be participatory processes you have to
have an agenda you have to publish in
the Federal Register these are the
things we want to work on for the next
one year and four years you get to you
have to take public comment on that are
your priority screwed up are you missing
something are you doing something
Overkill that you you know you keep
coming back to this and we need you to
do other things as I said you have to
show that there's a market failure to be
corrected now very often even before the
proposed rule uh agencies will put out
what they call a request for information
or an advanced notice of rul making to
bring in industry and affected and
experts to say okay these are the sorts
of studies you should be reading these
are the sorts of uh uh visits you should
make to companies and and innovators and
affected communities to get a handle on
how to start to uh circumscribe the rule
uh then most federal agencies have a
whole separate track where the small
business Lobby has successfully argued
with its own law now from the 1990s that
there has to be an entire public hearing
it's a private hearing but conducted in
front of the public with 15
representatives of small business and
they get to look at the proposal before
the public does and and there has to be
a written report of the small business
panel with the agency collaborating to
to write down how this rule is going to
be tailored for so that small business
can comply without undo economic harm it
may mean that workers of these small
companies or people who live Downstream
they may actually get more harm than
people affected by large companies
because the country has decided that
small business needs a break so that's a
whole another diversion back into the
major part of the process uh then we
often will have what they call
negotiated rul making committees where
instead of here's the rule let's talk we
actually have formal negotiations uh
presided over by a mediator with
industry and the affected public and we
all sit down and takes a couple years to
actually write the rule in that in that
way but assuming that doesn't happen it
goes into the regular uh process so
there's a proposal that comes out like
we have here but before it comes out
there are these endless meetings with
the White House Economist to say before
anybody can see it we're going to look
at every word and tweak it so that it's
more efficient it it gets the job done
with
with less cost all right public hearings
so I was and some of you were at the
dees Hearing in conquered on the 20th of
May I think it was 90 minutes it was
everybody gets their their three minutes
they were very generous they let people
come back a second time but it was one
way
no response other than thank you your
time is
up in the federal government and Most
states they are public hearings where
where there is Di dialogue and OSHA and
some other agencies have what I think is
is the best process it's the hardest to
get through but I say we I haven't been
there in many years but we would have by
by law the hearings would be presided
over by a judge and the agency would sit
at the podium and the witnesses would
come up one by one give their testimony
and cross-examine the agency and the
staff would have to answer on the spot
in front of a judge who would say
uh that's not a very you know we could
say we need to get back to you on that
but the hearing would always go for many
days so the judge would say fine I'll
you know I'll expect that answer
tomorrow and we'd go home and stay up
half the night and get the answer uh and
we could cross-examine the witnesses if
somebody came up there and and spouted
some junk science we had great people on
the staff who would very nicely say you
know have you taken math in like have
you figured out how add number like your
math doesn't add up uh your using a
paper that was retracted uh it's you
know it's a gray literature thing that
that nobody believes so it went both
ways and it's an outlier but most of our
hearings at OSHA went for about a week
so 40 hours of
testimony just before I got there they
finished the longest Hearing in human
history uh my my boss Robert Rice who I
Lov dearly great guy uh very smart guy
but he was way ahead of his time he
wanted to ban smoking in the in Federal
in in all in all private sector
workplaces in 1994 way ahead of his time
with all the literature about secondhand
smoke and the epidemiology of Cancer all
that good stuff but that hearing lasted
for five months five days a week eight
hours a day with a judge for five
months with yeah some people just lining
up around the block saying don't take my
cigarettes away and and we had to say
thank you you know we have heard this
but you have every right to add your
voice to the to the chorus but a lot of
Industry people uh and their um fellow
Travelers saying you know here's
scientific literature that says that
secondhand smoke is not so bad for you
or not bad for you at all and we had to
listen to all that uh we ended up
failing it was there's so much outcry
back then that it didn't happen but
that's the idea of what a serious public
dialogue is and it Bears no resemblance
to what uh we saw two weeks ago
okay then uh the final rule is written
and the big difference again contrasting
to here and I I will now show a slide of
this so again lot of words on the page
here but this is a rule I led the
development of in in the 1990s it is the
federal standard on respiratory
protection uh don't get me started uh
but here's one line from a a rule that's
probably 10 pages long the employer
shall identify a physician or other
licensed Healthcare Prof professional
plhcp to perform medical evaluations etc
etc one
sentence now I'm I'm cherry picking that
was a pretty controversial sense because
OSHA
had thanks in part to me had had decided
to change its standard rule from a
doctor must do everything to a licensed
healthc care provider including advanced
practice nurses and PAs people who were
already licensed by their state to do
certain things we realized that we had
been restraining trade and not allowing
um these you know highly qualified
people to do it anyway the point is in
the preamble to the final rule the
document that that contains the final
rule every sentence has an explanation
of why that sentence either was changed
or was not changed so this you can't
read it because it's so small but this
is about 1,200 words of why we changed
the doctor must do it to the licensed
healthcare provider can do it and as
you'll see just from the impression it
gives all kinds of references to the the
electronic docket which says these
Witnesses said we don't like this change
for these reasons these Witnesses says
we we do and there are literature
references that say we looked at all the
data and we decided based on these
studies and our evaluation of them that
that this change is good for the
following scientific legal economic
reasons you know contrast that
to we heard we heard a lot of stuff uh
yeah so are you familiar with I'm I'm
sure you are the bill um that um
actually got incorporated into another
bill that has now left the committee of
conference which will um kind of bring
New Hampshire a little bit forward up to
speed uh in regards with rules um and
then having to uh the agencies of course
having to post the public testimony as
well as um giving explanation um from
the testimony that came in about why
they you know um denied a rule or
accepted it or whatever so um right I
mean you deserve almost all the credit
for that I think with with chairman
Maguire of Judiciary yeah it does two
things I won't call the baby steps but
with all the stuff we have to do uh
they're they're it's a piece of the
puzzle but yes finally uh instead of
having to do a 9 1A request and drive to
conquered and read public testimony
which comes to the agency electronically
anyway they put it online like everybody
else does and that will take effect I
hope later this year and so people can
can see what are the other people uh
it's sufficient you know if somebody's
making your argument for you you don't
have to keep hammering the but if
somebody's making a fallacious argument
you get to see it and then yes there's a
new line in that bill that says the
agency has to I think it says uh
enumerate the facts data policy
decisions and judgments that cause them
to either accept or reject a sub
significant public comment so again
that's 40 years too late but it's a
great step
forward do you think there's a
possibility that um you know timing wise
when that
from from when that bill goes through
that will be able to um kind of maybe
force the hand of depending on timing
I'm not saying like if something some
rule was accepted 6 months ago I assume
that you know that won't happen but if
if rules are in the process now and and
and haven't been solidified um do you
think that we'll be able to in a sense
require agencies whether it be Dees or
even DHHS because they've got some
things coming too down the pike to be
able to say okay well we've got this new
law that's passed can you make sure that
it's applied yeah again it depends on
timing but my answer would be that they
should be you know someone should force
them to do it already it should have
been happening all along it should
happen tomorrow it should happen next
year whether it's the courts or public
opinion or the press or a new brand new
bill that will have to be written to say
you know this particular rule you know
pick one is accompanied with a response
document that's that's arrogant and
meaningless and haughty and we you know
the legislature is tired of that all
representative hins thank you drle
presuming that the federal agencies have
more resources to deal with are you
familiar with other states that are
doing a a rule writing process that is
distinctly different from New
Hampshire yeah I think the one the ones
I've advised I mean New Jersey is
clearly is you know clearly mimics the
federal system I I think I count Ed that
uh 36 states have an administrative
procedure act at least that that comes
right from the federal one of 1946 so
the majority of States at least have uh
requirements for public hearings that
are at least on paper supposed to be U
serious and not just one-way uh hearings
but I think the more important answer is
that of course these things will be you
know the states are are Miniatures of of
the federal system but the these are not
necessarily resource intensive in the
extreme or expensive in the extreme
obviously having a public hearing where
the agency is chooses to or is required
to to speak you know the people are
sitting there anyway so so asking them
or requiring them to interact cost
nothing a cost benefit analysis I'm I'm
going to give you an example now uh that
shows up a later but I'm U I'm taking
you know too much time to go through
these uh is this the one
well I'm I'm sorry here the next slide
was going to be uh something out of New
Hampshire uh again I tried not to pick
on something I'm I'm working on and have
an axe to grind about but but here is uh
uh Dees talking about protecting uh the
PCAT Pascal River and the the entire
response to uh a serious comment about
uh nitrogen U loading is uh the you know
we don't think there's a preponderance
of the evidence that this is a problem
and they might be right but just to say
we don't think so
uh uh oh yeah this was the one sorry so
I'm just trying to answer your question
more
concretely uh so I wrote written
comments on the dees landfill rule that
that the hearing was on May 20th and the
comment period was ended about a week
ago and uh I was pretty scathing about
the the main sentence in that rule which
is 5,000 to 50,000 times weaker than any
jurisdiction on the planet India Nigeria
Ireland Nova Scotia and every state I
found it's it's completely out of the
mainstream it's like looking at a the
agency said oh we're doing a speed limit
we looked at other states they're all
between 50 and 80 but we chose 5,000
miles an hour because we said so and oh
yes and then we weakened it to 50,000
miles an hour because somebody from the
industry said they'd never drive again
if they could only go 5,000 m an hour so
we went to 50 and uh that's why we did
it uh but I also wrote in those comments
how about stepping back and instead of
all of this page after page about uh
landfill shall have have plastic liners
and alarms and valves and a lot of good
engineering stuff what about a human
presence on the site what about a guard
365 and frankly I was a little sarcastic
because thees allows has allowed this to
happen
uh in Bethlehem a few years ago 3-day
weekend no one knew about a gigantic
leech a bill until Tuesday morning when
people showed up for work anyway my
point is I wrote in this comment
um you know why not add that sentence
and the the point is that in a in a
serious jurisdiction where public
comment was taken seriously that request
from you know just some guy would prompt
some kind of thought process
and the thought process would be pretty
simple how expensive is a is a full-time
guard I don't know is it 35k or 50k
that's a
number how what's the benefit of a
full-time guard you H hire somebody I
think I could do this in a day to go
online and find Historical examples
maybe there's already been a paper
written about it I don't know but
estimate the probability that a spill
will occur of a certain
magnitude at at night or over a weekend
and that's easy because it's the number
of hours in a week divided by the number
of hours nobody I mean it would be easy
to say over a 20-year planning Horizon
we would expect to avert two incidents
of certain variety if we had a guard and
then and then it's pretty easy to say
okay 100,000 gallons you know the cost
of of just cleaning it up even if it
doesn't hurt anybody and then compare
the 50k a year to the expected number of
averted incidents and say which one is
greater that's not a huge deal and yeah
state would be allowed would be expected
to do that more back of the envelope
than the feds would but it's still very
different from the response I expect to
nah thank
you representative ger thank you madam
chair uh so
one of the you know we can see the
consequence uh in in the case of
landfill sighting rules uh is that you
know we've Fallen literally decades
behind states around us and and and one
of the questions which comes up
frequently in our conversations with
Dees or points of contention at times is
is them saying well you know we're not
going to comment on what they do in
Maine or you know and on some level I
understand that right I mean it is not
their role to be experts in Main's rules
right but so could you speak to ideally
how the balance should be struck
between recognition that every state is
going to do things differently and that
they are Regulators for New Hampshire
and not for
Maine on the one hand with the fact that
we are impacted by that enormous
differential by states around us so how
is that balance struck between the unque
qualities of one State's rules and the
need to fit into the rules that are
prevalent in the states of the
region so I'm going to answer your
question but I'm going to start by
saying I I I came here to talk about
process and and and policy and and a
framework so I I guess my first answer
would
[Music]
be if almost every state and and the
federal system have been doing this for
many decades there's just no
justification for saying other than we
just want to be different or you know I
guess they could say we think every
other state is wrong and and Harry
Truman was wrong and Ronald Reagan was
wrong we have a better way but I've
never heard that so I don't see any
reason even if Maine was was different
geologically I just don't see any reason
why if if for decades it's been it's
been working right the Public Public
obviously does not feel happy about
every rule the federal government
government has put out or their state
has put out but there is clearly much
more um shall we say sort of you know
resigned uh affirmation that we didn't
get what we wanted but we we were heard
we went through a process it all made
sense we went to court we we had our
data you know a judge said it's a close
call but we I'm going to defer when you
lose a fight like that you feel like
okay you know win some lose some but I I
just can't imagine that that if people
understood
how how it's done elsewhere and how much
more of a chance you get to make a
case all through the process not just in
court but you know speaking to and
hearing from the people who work for you
in these agencies they wouldn't be
satisfied with this perfunctory process
now
specifically you know should our rules
look like other no I mean um we all have
different speed limits we all have
different uh degrees of uh you know
California's typically been the uh the
Vanguard and you know you have to the
big three now have to make their cars
for the whole country because they they
have to make them more efficient for
California that you can like that or not
like that but um there's no reason that
our state couldn't be stricter in some
ways and way less strict in other ways
if it was reasoned if it was we've
looked looked at everything and here
here we know we're different and here's
why and not just we're unique don't talk
to me about that's that could be Alpha
centor for all I know I don't know about
you thank you um so uh at the beginning
you mentioned the that uh it's the way
that New Hampshire's administrative set
structure is set up it is possible for
uh one individual to have an out uh
outweighted influence on the way that
administrative rule is actually executed
and uh what would need to change in so
what what what barriers to that exist in
other
states I think everything I've been
saying about I mean there there you can
obviously never legislate
against impr prety illegality uh there
are always going to be private meetings
there always going to be and and know
the president or the governor is always
going to have the the right and the
authority to to direct broad policy and
and you know and that's that was kind of
what I was trying to say earlier that
the pendulum will swing but all of these
procedures are designed so that it
doesn't swing wildly and erratically
it's kind of in between you know the 20
yard lines instead of way off uh you
know into the other end zone and so yeah
you're going to have new sheriff in town
who will say for the next two years or
four years I want things to be stricter
I want things to be less strict uh but
if you have a a system
where you know I didn't even talk about
this because I I'm not sure what new
hampsh would want to do but there are
there are there are penalties in other
jurisdictions for having once the clock
starts and you're supposed to be
listening to everyone uh it's called
expart communication you're not supposed
to invite either the industry or the
Environmental Group in for a private
session off the Record where where you
negotiate things and come out with a
different rule that's illegal in some
jurisdictions and again the difference
between being heard in the sense of I
was in the same room with the person I
who works for me at at at the
administrative agency so I got my five
minutes in the room with that person
versus I someone else was in a room with
that person and and got to negotiate
language and came out of that meeting
with getting back to the phone to the to
the client you know I negotiate you know
I got it from 1 time 10us 3 to 5 time
10us 3 on average for you you know I did
I did my job today that's night and day
you know it might have taken an hour in
public and an hour in private but the
entire uh structure and and AFF effect
of those two things is incredibly
different and as you know we have it we
have emails including one from former
assistant Commissioner of Dees
complaining to his Waste Management
director are you getting as tired of
being directed was the word he used in
our rul making by uh an industry lawyer
with a name as as we are I'm starting to
get you know a little antsy about
this thank
you so that leads me to this question so
in any of your time working uh in your
history you've got Decades of experience
did you work for an agent that ever was
like writing rules that would apply to
like many businesses but then um then
specifically the numbers were engineered
for maybe one specific purpose permit
application pending have have you ever
seen that in all your time and in all
your
experience short answer is no it it it
is and I've said this several times it
is it is regrettable it is unfortunate I
have some sympathy for Dees that they
are in a position of having Ru making
deadline at the same time as as one very
stubborn company is not only saying we
want our landfill in this tract and no
other but they're saying we want it now
and not later so they ha they
unfortunately have to and they're under
staff so the same three people maybe
it's six people but part of their day
they're writing the rule and part of
their day they're reading this
application but the data I'm convinced
that the data in the application has
been cut cut and pasted into the rule
and that is highly improper that is day
that representative Gera thank you uh so
you brought up a a point a few minutes
ago that I want to kind of lean in on a
little bit and and that is you know we
have seen with these rules as they were
drafted in in the various iterations
that in the initial draft we had a
standard 1 time 10 to than 5th which was
equivalent to what they have in Maine
that by the second draft had been
knocked down to what it is now 1 time
104 and the feedback that we received
was that they had heard from industry
that this was this was an unworkable
number so my question is as someone with
your experience what kind of red flags
does it raise when you see that kind of
change number one and number two
two what kind of evidence would you
expect to see to support that change
because it's certainly possible that
there is evidence that could be
presented that would demonstrate that
this change makes sense right but what
kinds of evidence as a regulator would
you expect to see when that kind of
weakening change is made in the draft of
rules so it's it's it's a two-part
answer first of all the the amount of
angst and and dismay uh the that I would
feel would depend on you know how much
weakened and and and how much further
out of the mainstream I mean I I make no
apologies I look
at I've I've sent to everybody a list of
I think 27 states countries provinces
and they're all way over here and New
Hampshire's way over here and and
getting further out so yeah if if if you
have a private meeting and you come away
with you know 10% more away from the
mainstream but still in the plausible
range okay that's one but starting from
a a ludicrous position and then going
five times worse and five times worse
and then changing the wording so that it
it could be any number of times worse
you know that's a that's
a neon red
flag um evidence so I think in this room
you you heard you asked this you
personally asked do director whims that
the same question and he forthrightly
said we have no we we were not given any
evidence we were we this was an
assertion that was made and I I I think
his implication was we we chose to
accept that assertion without evidence
and without any plans to collect
evidence and you know I would say in
addition to the impropriety of that uh
there is a a vast literature and vast
amount of common sense that says
industry will
always claim the sky is falling the the
estimates of how much things are will
cost are always exaggerated partly
because they do get cheaper over time
but partly because it's it's it's
strategy you you say that it's
impossible in the hopes that you won't
be asked to do what's possible and a
good regulator would would understand
that instinctively and not just well but
they said
so it was a not a good
day representative H
Haskins so are you saying Dr fle that um
this
rule the central CR creran is 500 to 50
times weaker than every other
regulation uh I don't have my notes I
believe it's 500 to 50,000 times words
depending on the jurisdiction there is
nothing there I've not and I wrote in my
comments if somebody wants to say it's
not the this weakest on the planet it's
the second or the third or the fourth
weakest or the 10th weakest apologies
for me and I'll I'll change my rhetoric
but I found nothing within a factor of
500 of and many that are 50,000 times
stricter in states which of course have
thriving landfill industry so back to
your question you know the the common
sense
is all the evidence goes in the in the
other direction not only do they not
have evidence the sky is falling but
they have evidence that the sky is not
falling across this border and that
border and that
border thank
you uh so have you watched all of our
subcommittee here hearings
every riveting
moment so if you could pick out maybe
the top or the top three things that
stand out in regards with all of the
hearings that we've had on on this rule
subcommittee what would you tell
us well the first one that comes to mind
I haven't I didn't mention it yet is uh
Mr Morel uh who came and spoke to you
about the rule making process in New
Hampshire and it was a beautiful you
know cogent
description you know he's much more
expert in New Hampshire than I am but I
I would assume he made not a single
error of of any kind it was a completely
perfect description of what happens here
and I would just say that to me stuck
out because this gentleman who obviously
is is incredibly well trained and has
you know devoted his life to this
understands the environment in this fish
tank and and and maybe doesn't
understand or just doesn't seem feel
that it's that it's important or
relevant to say this is our process but
we exist in a in a larger ocean in which
it's very different when you go outside
the tank and see how it's done elsewhere
so you know that that struck me as just
you know it would never change because
it is a it is in internally perfect
system it works exactly as it was
intended but somebody needs to step back
and say the statute has been updated you
know Harry Truman updated it for the you
know could it be intended to work
differently and then work as intended in
a in a different way uh I think mural
robinette's testimony was was terrific
um you know she's much more the
hydrogeologist than I am and and
explained in in great detail you know I
think she and I both believe again that
not only is the rule full of weird
ludicrous numbers that just jump out at
you as as coming out of fantasy land but
there are things missing and what she
said I think that's that that should
have hit home is uh that nothing in
these rules contemplates the applicant
really studying the entire site they're
supposed to study the first five feet of
the site in in vertical Direction and
when people are drawing water from a
gigantic aquafer 300 feet below grade
and the the applicant is not in
instructed to even think about that and
Dees is clearly you know not in a
position to say oh you didn't provide us
that so we'll go out we'll we'll walk
onto the site and do it ourselves
they're not going to do that so they
have described the skin of an onion and
they don't know whether there's an onion
underneath it or a time bomb it's
just I put Terra Incognito we have no we
have no idea and the rule the new rules
that are supposed to be the grand
updating do nothing to improve that
situation and I would just say you asked
for three so I would just say the the
admission from Mr whim that that that
they've been told it would be impossible
to make these rules stronger
and what evidence we have none and have
you even thought about how it's beled by
the experience of states in the region
that have strict rules and and thriving
Industries and are sending their trash
to us because uh you know they choose to
all so I have one more question and I
wantan to I want to give you the
opportunity to to kind of wrap up if
there's something that you missed and um
you know we're willing to go over a few
minutes just because it started late
um have you okay so I watched the the
rules um with Dees um public hearing and
I know many people were there there
weren't um there weren't any that were
there saying wow these are these are
great um there was only opposition and
do you you know do you have any further
comments about that in just in regards
with your experience in the process that
you could just um because you know I
would love people to hear this you know
to listen to this afterwards but um you
know any advice that you could give
moving forward especially you know
whether it be to the department whether
it to be to JL car whether it be to the
legislature yeah I was I was a I didn't
know what I've been to these hearings
before but I I you know I even wrote to
Dees in advance and said how much time
will people get you know do you have any
sense of you know 3 hours divided by n
is you know 5 seconds per person or I I
had no idea and then there were I think
probably 20 people including a couple of
of you came to uh to testify and yes
zero support for these rules now that
tells me two things one when director
whims says we have look I was a
bureaucrat we love to say we must be
doing something right if everyone's
unhappy well that that makes no sense I
mean you can you can make everyone
unhappy by by being clumsy and awkward
and illegal and you know so that's not a
good Criterion but is everybody unhappy
I don't think so
because the most affected what he calls
the most affected people are clearly
happy because they had their one
opportunity to say that they weren't and
none of them showed up
so you know I I only I I can think of
and makes perfect sense to me why would
someone come who had a hand in writing
every word of this rule other than to
sayg great job you know don't change
your that doesn't look right you can't
come to a process and say somehow wink
wink you've done a great job I wouldn't
change a word so there was nothing to
say and I have I've never seen that now
we knew in the federal system that that
we were trying to strike a balance
because we had the White House in
Democratic and Republican
administrations you know riding Herd on
us to make it cheaper and and and less
protective so we knew the Unions would
always Sue and we knew that business
would always Sue it it's just the way it
was and we didn't take it personally we
knew that the the first five years we're
writing it the next three years we're
defending it in court and God willing
we'd come out after eight years with a
rule that was was enforceable we got
sued over that healthc care provider the
AMA sued Us in in a heartbeat how dare
you let nurses and PAs uh take some of
our and we won the case but we had to go
is there anything else that you'd like
to add to kind in two minutes or less
I'll just say uh I I brought uh a couple
of copies so this uh report that we did
at pen of a multi-year project uh has a
a short summary it has a a large report
it has a book for the cameras called
achieving regulatory excellence and my
my boss and and colleague Carrie colines
he has continued to write books about
this and reports uh ever since and I
just want to quote uh from his words
because he's a great writer he said
regulating is hard work just doing it
well is demanding and difficult to
achieve Excellence at regulating
requires still more it requires
consistently and
superlatively mastering all of the
technical analytic and social task
needed to solve public problems so in
the in the lower left this again is
car's uh work he called it the the regx
the regulatory Excellence molecule and
it's got three parts uh kind of a ver an
adjective and a and a noun I guess maybe
a verb but talks about utmost integrity
and so the you know the maybe it's an
adverb I don't know you English teachers
uh not just some Integrity but you know
you have to be really uh willing to to
not Stray From the Path so it's it's uh
the quality of the process it's the
fairness of the process it's not having
private meetings it's not uh playing
Candy Crush on your phone when the
public is trying to explain that they're
AF afraid right or wrong for their
health or for their ecosystem or for
their view or whatever it is uh it's
empathic engagement it's not
just sighing deeply and saying we'll
listen to you for an hour you know how
much longer is this going to take
um uh I'm not a psychologist my my wife
is I know that representative H Haskins
is a counseling background um I didn't
know about this term until I worked on
this project but it's called apparency
transparency is important you can't
function without transparency but what
we learned I'll show you the the last
slide can't read it but it's a poster on
the wall uh we had
a two-day meeting with with First Nation
people in Canada about their regulatory
Acy the energy regulator in Alberta and
so they wrote things on the on the board
about what they thought about the the
agency that was putting you know the tar
Sands into development and you know a
lot of serious issues up there and and
and yet all that they really were
telling us was yeah we have to have
transparency we can't have you know
right to no requests ignored U that goes
without saying but what we want is
apparency we we want to understand if
something's being done to us we want to
understand why and if we get a a a
credible answer maybe we're even willing
to go back to our homes and live with
what we think is a weak rule or no rule
or a rule if if they will just do us the
courtesy of explaining here's what we
heard here's what we're balancing here's
what the evidence says and we know we're
creating winners and losers but that's
our that's our job I I really do believe
that that citizens or industry can go
home at the end of that process and say
we were heard we didn't we didn't get it
all we maybe we would get didn't get any
of it but it's the way government should
work and again without being um cynical
or offensive I move back to the state
and I don't see it working here and it
it bothers me because it can work and it
and it has to work so thank you thank
you Dr
finle yeah thank you so much for for
your time and um and your engagement and
um I guess we're officially I close I
can close the hearing I don't have a a
gavel I'm not that I can knock though so
that are in in study I think
[Music]
stud 1614 I think but I'll check that it
Ms
yeah yeah chairman ly just
just he had one point I I think we made
a drafting error at something about the
yeah I think we're probably okay yeah
like
everything
since we had a subcommittee meeting this
morning and I figured uh you know a good
portion of were some members of our um
uh environment agriculture committee
were going to be here uh I thought it
would be appropriate for us to gather uh
briefly and just discuss a game plan for
these uh three interim study bills which
we still have uh in front of us and
those three bills are HB 1351
prohibiting the sale and use of adhesive
baseed rodent traps HB 1685 redefining
Homestead Foods as Artisan Foods
creating excuse me an artisan food
operations exemption establishing
Artisan food products sales venues and
allowing the production and sale of
artisan food products requiring
Refrigeration as well as HB 1170
requiring public benefit and Community
impact assessments from the Department
of Environmental Services
now our committee
um uh voted those three bills uh to go
to interim study and they were uh voted
to go by the Full House as well so we
have these three bills ahead of us now
we cannot vote on uh interim study bills
today we are expected to have some sort
of uh subcommittees work on these three
bills
in one way shape or form and in the fall
we as a committee would then convene to
decide whether or not to
recommend uh either for each of these
bills either to uh that the
recommendation would be for further
legislation or no further
legislation um so with that uh I'd like
to um just
discuss a game plan we can um for each
of these bills have a subcommittee work
on them we can start working uh in June
now here uh um not today but uh we would
have the subcommittees work on these
throughout the summer um could have one
meeting two meetings as many as the
subcommittee deems appropriate to deal
with discussions on uh on these three
bills so um I would like representative
Bixby if you have any comment uh
regarding inter room study on these
bills I'd be happy to hear them all
right so um well in terms of uh ability
to work over them work on them over over
the summer there are restrictions that
the speaker puts on
doing uh legislative business during the
summer and I know that it has been a
July has been pretty much right out and
and uh and it's August has been somewhat
more flexible but uh in the last last
year it was kind of discouraged and I
know we don't get mileage for July and
August as well uh so um so I I think
that I so we need so I think we need to
think about these as either being you
know we work on them in the next two
weeks or we work on them starting in
September I think that's that that is in
terms of the way that our constru
straints are set up I think that's
probably a better way to think about it
um and uh so my feeling is um I'm not
ready to work on these in the next two
weeks
so fair enough so so so that that's
that's my sort of the overall impression
and then we can get down to discussing
the individual bills and I think we
should just sort of I I think it makes
sense
to um figure out uh is this something
that we feel we really need to uh devote
the work to and if so uh who is going to
be taking the lead on that work uh and
uh which doesn't mean and we have
existing subcommittees and can generally
fall to those existing subcommittees but
uh it doesn't mean that the chair of
those subcommittees would necessarily be
the person who was like doing the the
the main thrust of uh pulling things
together
okay question question representative
Penza so just asking about you know
interm study bills and um you know being
still well now I'm not a new rep anymore
because this like in the second year but
um I was told that you know I guess it
depends on the level of people that want
to be involved if they want to work on
it over the summer and engagement um you
know this the speaker can make an
exception and has uh for some of these
whether it be commissions and term
studies you know so if reps are coming
here um with mileage but so that is a
possibility but it just depends on you
know who really wants to be engaged so I
just wanted to make that just I don't
want to say you know we push it out that
you know no one wants to work on this
over the summer if we have people that
want to we can we can ask the speaker
for um for that so okay fair enough any
other comment representative Howard I I
just I just want to make it clear you
know I know in a lot of a lot of
committees they vote things into interim
study and it's sort of like death With
Dignity um and and I want to know that
the bills that we deem worthy of looking
further at as interim study that we
indeed do the work um that we say that
we're interested in doing otherwise why
not just itl the bill you know so um I
I'm I'm just I just feel it's very
important that it's not a death With
Dignity that these three bills we felt
um were not ready for prime time we did
not think that um the idea merited a
total itl and um so here we are and I am
glad to engage and and get these um
these bills discussed a little bit more
and and either recommend them for future
legislation or not so um representative
Howard I just have a technical question
um is it an interm study is it just
members of this
committee yes yes but uh you can the
subcommittee can invite other members of
the communities or stakeholders into to
help discuss uh different aspects of the
bill for instance I know with the uh
Homestead Foods I am very interested in
engaging convers ation with uh folks
from DHHS Food Safety Division as well
as um some of the farmers and people who
operate Homestead Farms uh sell food off
of their uh their different stands that
they have and uh I have already um you
know set an invitation for people to to
come and discuss what their concerns and
what their issues are that they'd like
to see address with uh any further
changes to food safety uh
legislation so does that answer your
question okay representative H Haskins
thank you madam chair um with regard to
1351 I am interested in the uh anti-glue
trap bill and I have done preliminary
research on it and I would be happy to
take the lead if I could get someone to
work with me I think that could be done
uh shortly and then when I in regard to
public benefit which I am supremely
interested in as well I think that's
going to take more time and effort so my
own view is that that could uh wait
until September when people are all
around and we can get organized to do so
okay well we we will discuss this
morning as so far as which subcommittees
we would um put this these different
bills to representative P
um hello ger I'm sorry pza ger yeah
potato potato it's Italian these Italian
names I'm so sorry than M pardon me um
so I just like to speak very briefly
about my interest in continuing work on
1170 that was uh I worked with the
sponsor the the prime sponsor
representative Thomas on a couple of
amendments and for those who may not uh
remember it one of the issues with that
was we simply didn't really have enough
time to explore those amendments um and
Dees didn't have an opportunity to
explore them enough to be able to
comment on them so we have a couple of
amendments uh that we can really begin
to work with I think whatever that
timeline is if it's through the rest of
June or picking up in September uh
that's where we would begin work and
consult with Dees uh and and try to
refine those but we have a couple of
amendments to to 1170 I think will be a
good place for us to pick up on that
bill okay representative Bixby yeah so
um there's there's one other bill that
um I'm blanking the number right now
it's the bill on uh on um Extended
producer responsibility which we had
talked about uh doing an ad hoc
committee study committee on that in um
and I think that that's something that
we also want to should should consider
should make sure that we deal with uh in
SE probably September okay well I'm not
sure that we need to do that work
because the solid waste working group is
doing uh a lot of work right now on epr
issues we're talking about um the
recycling of mattresses the recycling of
ewaste um there um paint recycling is
certainly going to be coming back um so
those are issues that are really that
are being explored Now by um Solid Waste
working group and I suspect that uh
representative eel and a few other folks
probably myself will be um developing
some sort of uh legislation for next
year okay are you looking in at uh
dealing with plastic waste yes okay so
uh um I guess that that was one of the
things that uh the the single use
Plastics that were part of that initial
bill um I think was one of the things
that I wanted to make sure that we BEC
because
there's that's that's a little bit more
complicated that it's fairly complicated
in terms of uh figuring out how to get
in get industry on board in a way that's
going to be effective and meet the um
the goals that um environmental groups
are also interested in making sure
happen and I wanted and I was so I was
thinking if we if we did that at ad hoc
study then that would be a um that that
would I think might be the main target
there's certainly no harm in doing that
I I I would be fine with that if you
wanted to you know grab a a couple of
people from this committee and maybe
have uh representative eil included in
it as well um to you know bat around
some ideas for that um
because yes a solid waste working group
is looking into some of those things but
you know I don't know to what extent
they're going to have any particular
piece of legislation put together and
I'm what I'm thinking about is that
getting the uh in terms of principles I
think that the solid waste group is
doing is is you know their leadership is
really important but in terms of
figuring out the nuts and bolts of how
are we going to put a bill together uh
and getting the input from multiple
stakeholders I think that might be
something that that an ad hoc committee
could do okay that sounds
good um all right
so we have um one two three four five
six seven sevenish subcommittees already
put together there's an environment for
this committee an environmental policy
subcommittee an agricultural policy and
current use subcommittee an animal
protection and Licensing subcommittee a
solid waste
subcommittee um certainly the one that
met this morning the dees rules update
subcommittee and uh I have assembled a
new subcommittee food safety
subcommittee so um hb1
1351 prohibiting the sale and use of
adhesive based rodent traps I'm kind of
trying to figure out which would be an
appropriate um policy subcommittee to to
put that
under
um I'm I'm leaning more towards the
um ADV agricultural policy and current
use
because since Farmers seem to use some
of these rodent traps I don't know maybe
it's not maybe it's more environmental
what I don't know what you would it's
more of animal protection so I I think
that the the the justifications for the
bill that were brought to us had to do
with um these traps are cruel uh these
traps have uh Wildlife um you know
bycatch
implications uh which seems to be kind
of in the animal realm you could also
say that's kind of in the environmental
realm I would I would more say the
Environmental Policy simply because um
you know we're talk talking about the
same kind
of Realm as pesticides and rodent
control
um I I don't know i' I'd be fine with
either I
suppose um but okay so could you just on
yeah Environmental Policy subcommittee
uh representative Bixby chair
representative veral brulard ktoa Penza
I I should have an animal and and the
animal protection is kraton chair Kenny
smart kulon H Haskins moris Murray and
Duty represent Howard thank you um I I I
would argue for agriculture because the
strongest argument made for keeping
representative Penza has a
question yeah I think that all of the
opposition was this was a really hard
Bill and there was so there was I mean
we had I mean it was crazy hours and
hours and we received so much
information over email about this and
most of it was people that were using
these in the wrong way because if
they're used in the correct way there
shouldn't be a problem we should never
you know have um there shouldn't be
wildlife and in animals or kittens and
all of these different types of things
Birds um that are caught in these
because they're not made to be put like
outside and stuff so you know that on
that piece you you see the animal but
it's in the intents and purposes all the
opposition was to protect from that so
it really I don't know it's I think it's
more of an environmental than than it is
representative NAB um I just want to
agree with that because I think the
stakeholders you're going to want to
have in the conversation are Farm groups
and Pest Control groups we know that
animal rights groups are going to
support this bill right so those aren't
the people we need to bring to the table
I think um if we have a conversation
forward
okay well I'm going to I'm going to
suggest that it it is
um sent to the Environmental Policy
subcommittee so representative Bixby I I
I would like you to uh come and Deere
that effort I I don't know if you I mean
you don't you can have a subset of that
committee meet if you don't want to take
the charge of actually dealing with the
bill so um so and and I will you know I
will be happy to chare it and then um
basically moderate the sessions but I I
um in terms of but it sounds like
representative H Haskins has a lot of
ideas about how to go forward with that
um would you be okay with not actually
doing our meetings until uh September
sure
okay okay so we we agree that it should
go to environmental policy subcommittee
and you guys are going to uh Begin work
on it in
September
okay super Allison uh representative NAB
I'm sorry summer
fine I can can you attend a subcommittee
meeting or be a part of a subcommittee
that you're not on if you're interested
like I'm interested you may attend you
may not be at the table okay yeah uh in
the past we um members who are not on
subcommittee can attend they can be at
the table they can ask questions but
they can't vote ah gotcha gotcha okay
thank you for clearing that up all right
cool all right uh then we have the HB
1685 uh the homestead Bill and um that
would go to this food safety
subcommittee I'd be happy to chair that
um and that also on that committee is uh
representative Bixby representative
kulan representative ktoa representative
sofikitis and representative
Murray and
um I am going to see whether or not
anybody is interested in beginning any
kind of work to begin the work sometime
in June here and then finish up any of
work over the summer um simply
because um we have folks on board who
are interested in in uh having those
conversations fairly
soon you know we can wait but um Let me
let me find out from um the folks that
I've spoken to the stakeholder folks
that I've spoken to people at Farm
Bureau um and so forth and see what the
their preference would be but I'm I'm
amable to beginning any kind of work in
June
so I'm fairly constrained in June so um
I there's a handful of days where I
might be able to make it but um but I'm
doing a lot of construction on my house
understood and my brother is actually
able to come up and help me which is
okay that's okay that that's kind of a
significance constraint yeah represent
seacus
good morning um your chairman um I'm
delighted to help you work on this bill
in June wherever you'd like to I'm free
all right wonderful thank
okay yeah
um and you know we're not with any of
these bills it doesn't necessarily mean
that you have to take the bill itself
and reward it and rework it and resubmit
it as a bill in the fall you can come up
with something totally different um it's
it's the up to the committee to decide
though um with the with the dis
conversations that they have on on
this
would warrant further legislation or not
which is what the subcommittee would
recommend to the full body uh when we
meet in the fall representative Bixby
yeah so um
and so in terms of the the the strict
details yes the the committee is just
recommending whether it whether or not
it needs further legislation um ideally
a good you know a a
well uh a well done in term study uh if
there if if it's recognized that it
makes sense to do um to do further
legislation it often makes sense to uh
help at least begin to to work out the
structure of that legislation although
it would be an individual member who is
reelected who would be actually
sponsoring the bill for the next term
correct okay represent
Penza so I just had a question about
timing so let's say um you know stuff is
worked on in June or even in the summer
um like this bill that we're talking
about so um in if it's put in and you
know is there a way that this is like in
a sense an early bill or fast-tracked
you know there so no no so this just
goes into the regular stream of our
bills come you know if if I mean if
there's if there's any kind of financial
um aspect to the bill that you're going
to file that would be an early Bill the
beginning of next year okay but in terms
of being an early Bill or fast-tracked
Bill kind of thing um but other than
that it would just go into the regular
pile of bills that the legislature would
uh would
consider the thing is that we have two
times in which to be able to file bills
there is an early filing for um for the
I guess it's uh September sep yes so so
there's there's an early filing period
which is usually a week or two in
September and that is for essentially
um current members and often the the
main usefulness of that is if you want
to say well I filed in your campaign I
filed a bill on this or that or the
other thing and uh and oh Wells doesn't
actually do a whole lot of work on those
bills until uh after the election
because if the M Prime sponsor of the
bill does not get reelected then they
would have done a bunch of work that you
know is not going anywhere uh
so uh in just in terms of strategy for
interim study bills and and legislation
that comes out of them it makes sense to
just aim for that November fining period
that's right after the election y
because that way uh you have that time
to work in the fall uh it's not going to
get there's no advantage of trying to
get it out by September right so uh you
can get the work you can get a more
thoroughly worked out Bill to oh which
makes the which will get things moving
faster than uh than trying to get it in
sooner correct okay thanks
representative ger thank you madam chair
could you remind us who the members of
the solid waste subcommittee are because
I know I'm on that and I'd like to work
on it but I want to know who the chair
is other MERS that's uh representative
Murray is the chair of that and we have
representative brulard Davis kulan Penza
NAB saitis and German okay thank you I
perhaps reach out to representative Mur
about what timeline might work for her
yes indeed yeah so uh so that would be
that would be HB
1170 and that would go to the solid
waste
subcommittee and um I did send out a
copy of this list of subcommittees to
committee members I will send it out
and I'm sorry that I did not make copies
for everybody for today but okay okay
representive H Haskins thank you madam
um aliceon NAB for animals to solid
waste
and representative Bixby agreed and I
think you saw no reason not to switch
that's correct now that you refreshed my
memory about that email so that's fine
okay um so for the solid way
subcommittee I would uh swap out
representative NAB for representative H
Haskins and put representative NAB on
the animal protection subcommittee which
I guess won't be meeting so it's it's
fine there you
go
okay um it's so let me let me take care
that yeah yeah that is the only
subcommittee that she was
on it might be a move point balance at
this point but we it should probably be
and some people are on several
one it just in terms of
um making things even but I don't I'm
not sure that it
you
yeah oh okay you're just having a okay
all right so um so we will uh assign
those bills to those particular um
subcommittees and uh I'll leave it up to
the chairs
to figure out when they want to meet and
uh we as a committee would then return
back in
September uh with some recommendations
from those subcomittees as to whether or
not uh the bills require further
legislation or not and we might
conceivably October depending on how
much work right
yep okay any other questions comments
for the good of the
committee representative ger uh I would
like to just go on the record and thank
Madam chair for her letter to uh de with
the questions regarding leech a
treatment and concerns about NC's cap
capacity to deal with the lee8 so I very
much appreciate you speaking on behalf
of the committee and asking some great
questions thank you and I am still
waiting for a reply from Dees who has
promised this to me um they said early
this week so I'll wait till
Wednesday I I second that thank you yeah
thank you I I appreciate that um you
know I I did um appreciate the emails
that I've re received uh with various
concerns um on a lot of different things
but the uh topic of leech 8 and and how
it's been handled and how much of it etc
etc uh certainly warranted a uh an email
to um both uh commissioner Scott and
director whims sat about so hopefully we
will hear something of substance from
them and if not then I will be very
concerned
might an indication of a need for
legislation absolutely
absolutely um and I I am certainly
expecting a uh another flurry of uh
Solid Waste bills next year so uh I know
this is to be
continued um certainly been
um disappointing from what we've seen in
the senate in terms of their inaction
but um
you makeup make up of yeah government
next term we might have more luck with
some of the bills that
we passed unanimous unanimously out of
our
committee yes not I reserve for any
further comment you're on the record
still yes I know TI is
yeah so um I all I would like to in with
that uh thank you all for all your hard
work this past year and this past two
years it's been um really a pleasure to
chair this committee with all these fine
folks working so very hard uh on very um
interesting and sometimes very difficult
issues and I'd like to just say that um
I really appreciate your leadership and
the way that you have uh really upheld
the the tradition of this committee to
work in a nonpartisan way and to have a
very uh thorough discussion among the
leadership of both in both parties on
the committee and then extending that to
the entire membership of the committee
thank you thank
you thank you so with that I'd like to
invite you all Katherine representative
sofikitis
sorry I just wanted to thank you for
your work for the last two years it's
been a joy again to be on this committee
thank you it's been great to have you as
well and I'd like to invite uh members
of our committee to uh come to Barley
House for some lunch and I'm I'm afraid
I'm not going to be able to make it my
kids are here just until early tomorrow
morning so I'm gonna be heading home
tomor all right well you you enjoy your
family and have safe travels thank you
all